major US cities shut down to stop the
spread of the wolf flu but as we rush to
save our lives as coronavirus killing
our Constitution we will examine the
surprising civics lessons of the
pandemic then former future Democrat
governor of Florida and potential vice
president candidate Andrew Gilliam is
found vomiting in a hotel room with a
naked male prostitute and a bunch of
meth we will analyze as it were how the
press let him off the hook finally DNC
chairman Tom Perez illustrates the
left's two contradictory takes on
religion all that and more i'm michael
knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
all right what's the latest with our
pandemic that we've got running around
all of our city's new guidelines add
from the Trump administration the Trump
administration is calling this 15 days
to slow the spread typical stuff in here
so it says stay home if you're sick stay
home if you're old stay home if you're
frail
don't gather in groups of 10 or 20 or 30
people don't host any mosh pits don't go
to any raves so be kind of what you
would expect but all of that is
secondary to the most interesting thing
in the document which is the very first
line the very first line says listen to
and follow the directions of your state
and local authorities now if there is a
silver lining of the wolf loop
amid the death and the economic
devastation and worst of all the closed
bars very frustrating if there is to be
said some sort of silver lining it is
this people are learning more about
federalism we'll get to that in one
second first I got to thank our friends
over at legacy box I really love these
guys I have had a lot of photos lying
around for years now well over 10 years
and what happens the photos start to
fade you throw em in a drawer somewhere
you forget about them you lose them they
disappear and then that's it and for
relatives who maybe aren't with us
anymore
you might have lost every memory of that
person legacy box is a way for you to
easily and affordably digitally preserve
your past and it's unbelievably easy you
just pack it up and send it over and
then you receive perfectly preserved
digital copies on a thumb drive DVD or
the cloud I love it I just did it with a
lot of photos of relatives of mine who
are no longer with us I'm so grateful
that this exists you can get started
today on preserving your past go to
legacy box.com / Knowles ko wles to get
an incredible 40 percent off your first
order
buy today to take advantage of this
exclusive offer send it in
when you're ready that is legacy box
komm slash Knowles kena wles save 40%
while supplies last they're actually
learning more about our federal system
of government Mollie Jong fast who is a
liberal who is all over Twitter and she
writes for The Daily Beast I think she
writes for the bulwark she tweets out
quote so the states are basically
governing themselves because our
president doesn't know how to president
at all are you gonna tell her or should
I
maybe well I think a lot of people
actually already told her this on
Twitter the states are basically
governing themselves because we have a
form of government called federalism so
whether it be during a pandemic or
whether it just be during a regular
Tuesday the states at least
theoretically are supposed to mostly
govern themselves because we have a
federal system of government actually it
looks like the president knows very well
had a president because the federal
government of Washington DC is not
supposed to make every single decision
for how we run our lives actually it's
supposed to make very very few of those
decisions it took a worldwide pandemic
to get liberals to read the Constitution
so that's what we're seeing from the
federal level there actually is some
drastic action being taken right we saw
the last couple days the Federal Reserve
is cutting interest rates there's a
program of quantitative easing that's
going to go into effect which is
basically just printing money to help
stimulate the economy President Trump is
waving interest on student loans there
are a Small Business Administration
loans coming out there's disaster relief
coming out and now we're seeing that the
White House and Congress are talking
about a potential 850 billion dollar
stimulus package as so a lot of a lot of
money or is it million dollar I guess
these days you know with the Liberals it
doesn't really matter million billion $1
for from Mike Bloomberg a million
dollars from Mike Bloomberg anyway some
sort of stimulus it's still it's still
in the works they're going to be talking
about it's gonna put President Trump in
a difficult position though because he's
going to have to
attack President Obama's economic
policies and yet it looks like these
might be similar things to what we saw
in 2008-2009 another very important
thing from the federal government the
elimination of the payroll tax big boost
to employees and to employers that would
be very very good but most of the
decisions that affect our lives and
they're affecting our lives during this
pandemic are coming from the state and
local level okay so we're now seeing in
Los Angeles disaster has finally hit
because they closed all the bars so the
bars are closed restaurants are closed
certain shops are closed I mean it is it
is pretty weird that's not what's
happening in every town across America
that's just what our schmucky mayor Eric
Carr said he decided to do Eric our city
who has not dealt with the homeless
problem once homelessness increased 16%
during his time in office in just one
year but now all of a sudden we're going
to shut the bars that's gonna slow the
spread of the pandemic San Francisco
putting the whole city on lockdown
Ohio canceling the presidential
primaries today and actually you saw
some disagreement between two branches
of government there because the governor
wanted to cancel the primaries and not
have people come out and vote a judge
said he did not have the authority to
cancel the primaries and so the governor
of Ohio Mike DeWine decided just not to
open the polling places so they say okay
judge you made your decision but I can
decide whether or not to open these
places and if they're not open then you
can't vote is this constitutional
probably I don't know if it's legal but
it might it's probably constitutional in
that not everything hateful or odious is
covered by some provision of the
Constitution the Constitution at least
in theory is supposed to reign in the
power of our federal government but it
actually gives the states and localities
a lot of leeway to govern actually this
is a big big element of a debate going
on on the right right now between the
libertarians and the more traditional
conservatives the libertarians are
saying you know the government can never
pass any kind of regulations ever it's
always terrible it's always
unconstitutional and what the
traditional conservatives are looking at
is saying well act
maybe the federal government doesn't
have the authority to do that but state
and local governments have always had
the authority to do that I mean we think
about just think about the First
Amendment First Amendment says there
there cannot be an established church in
America right for the federal government
of America so the Liberals interpret
that to be a total separation of church
and state that's not what the framers
intended at all that's not what they
meant how do we know that because we
know that states had established
churches the federal government was not
allowed to but the states were allowed
to and actually the reason that the
federal government was not allowed to is
to permit the states to do just that so
you might agree or disagree with the
decisions of the states here but that's
not really a constitutional question
that's more a question of the law of
your state or the elected officials that
you have put into office so we got the
political update that's what's going on
it's changing by the minute we'll keep
you posted the economic update the
global economy could lose between 1.1
and 2.7 trillion dollars as a result of
leung pao chicken that is a lot of money
1.1 and 2.7 trillion dollars okay and
those aren't just numbers floating in
the air that actually affects the lives
of people 2.7 trillion dollars what's
the economy of the United States I mean
I think the federal budget of the United
States is three and a half four trillion
dollars something like that so you're
talking about a huge portion of that or
maybe the but the budget is a little
higher than that because we're always
running a deficit that's that's another
problem with our federal government but
still you're talking about a huge amount
of money with regard to our economy and
that could be gone I just got a letter
in from a listener to the show from
Jennifer hi Michael I'm a huge fan and
wait impatiently for your show I keep
hearing about this mandatory two-week
paid leave by companies employing 50 or
more I work at a hotel on i-40 in
Amarillo Texas we deal with travelers
coming and going literally across our
nation most hotels motels do not employ
50 people and my employer does not
for any paid leave i among others can't
afford even one day off we're at
extremely high risk to coronavirus we
Clorox wipe as often as possible and use
hand sanitizer what else do you think we
can do that wouldn't be off-putting or
give guests the wrong idea
also what do you think if anything
should be done to help us during this
time a couple questions in there so
let's get the easy one first I think
that by Clorox in everything by having
those hotel and motel rooms reeked of
cleaning supplies you will put your
customers at ease okay nobody I know
sometimes cleaning supplies smell you
don't want that when you get into a
hotel during a pandemic you do you
that's like the sweetest perfume you can
smell so I think probably that would put
the customers at ease what can be done
for people who can't afford to miss work
you are far from alone this is true for
the vast majority of people in this
country they can't afford to miss work
and that's the consequence here that
nobody is talking about when it comes to
the response to this virus there are
real consequences to hysteria everyone's
saying better to over react than under
there under react is that true maybe
it's true I'm not so sure about that
okay so what's the first consequence of
hysteria people's nerves people are
losing it man people are on edge
especially if you look on Twitter which
I don't recommend people are losing
their minds also there are some
businesses that are closed now that
don't need to be closed I just saw
Pennsylvania's gonna close the liquor
stores are you gonna close the liquor
stores that doesn't make any sense the
liquor stores are not places where
people congregate all the time this is a
it doesn't add up
we will get to the two popular views on
the economic front here but first we've
got to thank our friends over at
NetSuite what do companies like ring
hint and to Kovas all have in common
they all use NetSuite to accelerate
their growth successful companies know
that in order to grow faster you must
have the right tools men
sweet will give you the visibility and
control you need to make the right
decisions and grow with confidence
that's why NetSuite customers grow
faster than the S&P 500 NetSuite is the
world's number one cloud business system
trusted by more than 19,000 companies
it's the last system you will ever need
NetSuite business grows here it is one
of these things happens all the time
when businesses are starting out they
don't know their numbers okay they don't
they've got different systems they're
not talking to one another yet NetSuite
you will thank me later
schedule your free product tour right
now and receive your free guides six
ways to run a more profitable business
and NetSuite comm slash Knowles canna
wles
that's NetSuite comm slash Knowles canna
wles what is it say to me again NetSuite
cop / Knowles so you've got businesses
closing now that don't need to close
there is a cost to that ok you know
we're gonna lose one point one to two
point seven trillion dollars out of the
global economy that's gone that just
disappears it's not like you get to
bring that back later ok that's gone all
this wealth that we have in this country
comes from our ability to produce things
countries that are very prosperous or
prosperous because people are working a
lot they're producing a lot of things
countries that are not prosperous it's
not just some luck of the draw
whoopsie-daisy most of the time the
reason that they're not prosperous is
because they don't have systems in place
that allow people to produce things and
to work and to make a lot of money so
when you're just sitting on the couch
for two weeks there's no way to fix that
there's no magic pill to make that all
better you've got to be producing things
so just to use a easy example in LA I
have friends who are waiters and
waitresses they're not gonna be able to
pay their bills maybe they'll get the
payroll tax maybe that will help maybe
they'll get unemployment maybe but it's
gonna be very difficult to pay their
bills there are two popular opinions on
this both of which are wrong and
demagogic but they're very popular
there's
one view we can call it the political
viewpoint that view is we should pay no
attention to any economic questions we
should be willing to shut down
everything grind the entire global
economy to a complete halt if it means
that it increases our chances of making
people healthier by 1% or half a percent
or half of a half a percent forget the
economic questions alter what monster
are you that you would consider economic
questions during a natural disaster
during a time of pandemic ok that's the
political viewpoint you're hearing this
especially by the people who are getting
hysterical online then on the other side
there's what you might call the economic
viewpoint and the economic viewpoint it
basically says hey guys look some people
are gonna get sick especially old people
especially frail people but who needs
them anyway let's not stop the economy
at all let's just keep things going as
usual and we'll figure it out it'll be
ok this is what you're seeing happened
in places like the Netherlands where
they're they're basically pursuing the
strategy of herd immunity and saying
keep everything going you'll figure it
out some people are gonna get sick
whatever too bad some people are gonna
die even worse but hey that's life we'll
figure it out at least we won't stop
producing things this you might call the
economic model doesn't view people
exactly like people that fuse them more
as cogs in a machine no no
responsibility here to take care of
people both of those views get it wrong
why because politics is not just
politics economics is not just economics
this is the problem especially you see
this when you have experts running the
economy experts running our government
is they only focus on their one area of
expertise they miss the forest for the
trees politics and economics and other
viewpoints tell us about society about
real things about real men and women so
we want a civilization that views human
beings as human beings full human beings
men and women with dignity
who'sa lives matter whose lives cannot
just be expended by some cold
calculation right
we also want a civilization we don't
want to descend into chaos what's gonna
happen let's say they shut down Los
Angeles they've completely lock it down
business is shut down you're supposed to
stay home how long is that gonna last
before people start losing it this is
Los Angeles okay when when the roads get
a little wet you know when it rains once
or twice a year people lose their minds
there's like violence in the streets
basically what's gonna happen when that
city is completely shut down for a week
or two weeks or three weeks young people
are just gonna okay that's fine we'll
just stay at home we'll just watch
Netflix I don't think so other cities to
San Francisco you think it's gonna be
like that San Francisco's got public
defecation on the best of days what's
gonna happen when things start to go hey
water what's can happen when people
can't go to establishments can't go to
coffee shops can't go to bars can't go
to restaurants can't go anywhere they're
gonna get restless idle hands are the
devil's playground all right and
especially in places that already are
not the most peaceful all the time
that's not a great thing so you've got
to take that into consideration
and by the way Europe is not a guarantee
of what's gonna happen in the United
States I got into a lot of trouble with
left-wing blue checkmark Twitter the
other day because I said that the United
States is not Italy that's not saying we
shouldn't take the wuhan virus seriously
but it is to say Italy has the oldest
population in Europe they kiss each
other when they greet one another and
they haven't had a functioning
government since Octavian it's kind of a
flippant way of pointing out there were
big cultural differences here well
here's another big difference
Europeans are used to being absolutely
subservient to their governments okay
there is at least continental Europe
maybe not the UK the anglo-american
tradition of Liberty the anglo-american
tradition of not letting the government
push your and tell you what to do all
the time is a very real thing you don't
see that in continental Europe you do
see it here how long are we gonna be on
lockdown before some American says like
I know I don't think so I think I'm
gonna go out there sir where's your
to walk outside yeah here's my license
probably lift up one of their fingers
okay there is a there is an attitude in
the United States that does not like to
be pushed around by our government
you've got to take that into
consideration as well okay right now
it's considered impolite to talk about
economics the reason for that is there
is no political cost to overreaction
there's gonna be a massive cost right
people are gonna lose their jobs they're
gonna lose their livelihoods
who knows they're very easily someone
could be harmed or died as a result of
this perfectly simple to consider
someone can't get the services that they
need that they rely on every single day
but because of the disruption of the
global economy they're not able to get
it so even just in terms of life or
death certainly that could be a
consequence but there will be no
political costs to that if you were a
mayor or a governor of a state or the
president of the United States for that
matter all the political cost is on
under-reaction because you get all the
negative headlines of 20,000 people died
25,000 people died and it doesn't matter
if you could point to it and say that's
fewer people than died from the flu that
won't matter the headlines will be there
and so you've got every incentive to
overreact but the headline will never be
the economy ground to a halt because
guess what the economy around the world
grind to a halt you say of course we had
to do that to save lives and you can't
prove a negative so that will be a
successful political argument but just
as we should avoid an emotional response
when it comes to panicking or not
panicking that was our show yesterday
hysterics aren't helping just as we
avoid an emotional response there so -
we should avoid an emotional response
when it comes to simplistic answers here
all right these are very complex
questions and we should not entirely
ignore the political side we should not
entirely ignore the economic side of
things we've got to take them as a whole
because they're all part of the same
question which is of society now there
is one simple question in all this the
question is what do we call this virus
what do we call it president
had an answer yesterday he tweeted out a
reference to the Chinese coronavirus
okay Trump has been doing this the whole
time see yesterday tweets the United
States will be powerfully supporting
those industries like Airlines and
others that are particularly affected by
the Chinese virus we will be stronger
than ever before and the left they're
furious about this so how dare you call
it the Chinese virus what just because
it's a virus that comes from China it's
all of a sudden its Chinese yeah uh-huh
that's true they say that's racist
that's xenophobic oh the letters I've
got show you the tweets the messages the
emails that I've gotten from left
wingers who are irate that I would refer
to the Chinese virus or the Wuhan virus
or and anything that talks about the
origin of this illness they have short
memories because if they could remember
even back a week ago or two weeks ago
they would see the President Trump and I
were simply taking our cues from the
mainstream media at least six people
have died from the Wuhan corona virus
the Wuhan corona virus has now surpassed
the 2003 SARS outbreak and the number of
lives it's claimed they're under
quarantine out of concern that
passengers and crew were exposed to the
Wuhan coronavirus and this breaking news
just in to CNN the official death toll
from the Wuhan coronavirus in China's
Hubei Province has now risen to 780
having to deal with it the total number
of deaths from the Wu hen coronavirus
it's now surpassed the SARS outbreak
from 2002 to 2003 2003 spreading fast as
the number of confirmed cases of the Wu
hen fires continue to surge in a matter
of days doctor Li wind young went from
treating patients to becoming one the 34
year old ophthalmologist diagnosed
Saturday with the Wuhan corona virus if
new information about how the Wuhan
corona virus is spread the Wuhan virus
which originated as we know in Wuhan
China just in case the name Wuhan virus
didn't give
an idea where it's from it's from Wuhan
China I could play another 10 minutes of
that montage okay that's just like 50 or
55 seconds I could go on and on on
everybody was calling this the Wuhan
virus the Chinese virus the whole
mainstream media and then a bunch of
cynical leftists decided wait a second
this might be an almost plausible
opportunity to baselessly smear our
opponents as racists like we usually do
you know because it's almost plausible
because it involves a location and
locations can sometimes imply race and
so anyway you're all bunch of racists
they don't even remember that two weeks
ago they were all doing this forget the
Spanish flu the Ebola the West Nile
virus forget all of that they themselves
unsee n n on NPR and all of these
stations we're doing it just a couple
weeks ago New York Times and now those
very same outlets are saying it's racist
and bigoted and terrible really pathetic
stuff guys it shows you how the left is
willing to exploit any little thing and
when they tell you that Trump and
conservatives are not taking this
seriously play the Mac lip who's not
taking this seriously I think we're
taking it very serious I think we're
taking it much more seriously than the
left we've got to get to Andrew Gilliam
speaking of unserious people and
speaking of sick sick stuff we'll get to
Andrew Gilliam who was found hurling in
a hotel room next to a naked male
prostitute surrounded by a bunch of meth
probably just a coincidence produce an
accident we'll get to that in one second
first take one quick question from a
listener from Casey Michael can you do
an impression of your sweet little ELISA
I need to smile this morning now okay
let's go to the daily wire website let's
get out of Facebook and YouTube we've
got a whole lot more to get to but we'll
have to take a quick break it's 20/20
we've only just begun what is bound to
be the most insane year for news since
the last presidential election that time
we didn't even have a global pandemic
now more than ever is the time you need
to be a daily walk
subscriber right now you can receive 10%
off any plan when using promo code
Knowles K no W l e s that's 10% off all
those wonderful things you get me been
drew Matt Walsh all-access Q&A is you
get everything 10% off all of that when
you use promo code Knowles canna wles so
head on over to daily wire.com and come
join the fun daily where calm we'll be
right back
all right Andrew Gilliam poor Andrew
Gilliam what happened the former future
governor of Florida Andrew G ylim found
vomiting in a hotel room surrounded by a
bunch of meth and a naked male
prostitute who worked for rent men calm
it's like you might've might as well be
from illegal sex calm I am committing a
crime calm not a great look if you are
in politics or even if you're not in
politics you don't want to be found
hurling by the police surrounded by a
naked gay prostitute and drugs Gilliam
the story is that he went to a wedding
yeah he had a little bit too much to
drink look you and I we know this we
know what happens you go to a wedding
right you have one or two few too many
drinks maybe and then next thing you
know you wake up in a hotel room next to
a naked health prostitute and a bunch of
meth how many times does that happen to
us so that's the story never touched the
meth who was that guy I don't know who
that naked male prostitute is mind you
Andrew Gilliam is married with three
kids married to a woman I know that
these days you have to specify that
married to a woman with three kids is so
really really bad look the guy just
signed on as a CNN contributor
unfortunate I'm not bringing this up to
a dunk on Andrew Gilliam at least that's
not the only reason I'm doing it he was
a really unlikable candidate for
governor he was one of these people who
was insinuating that the election might
be rigged and fixed he was really awful
and I'm glad he lost his election
especially now now that we know who he
is the reason I bring it up is this guy
was still being talked about as a
potential vice presidential candidate
because Democrats always do this if you
lose you win somehow I don't know you
lose up Stacey Abrams lost the Georgia
Governor race now she is still seriously
being considered as a vice presidential
candidate she's like a top-tier vice
presidential candidate beta or work
loses the Texas Senate race then all of
a sudden he's the Vanity Fair cover
glossy photo
for president Andrew Gilliam same thing
a Politico ran this story another
Democrat gets a 20/20 look Andrew
Gilliam this was just about a year ago
they ran it the Florida Democrat got a
standing ovation at a closed-door DNC
meeting even in defeat Democrat Andrew
Gilliam is proving to be one of the
winners of 2018
the former tell a c-- mayor is parlaying
his razor thin loss in the Florida
governor's race into a role in the 2020
presidential primary as a kingmaker or
perhaps even a candidate himself wow man
that guy is gonna go places daily beast
daily beast reported that Elizabeth
Warren remember her she was considering
Andrew Gilliam to be her vice
presidential running mate probably not
anymore
here is the Andrew Gilliam statement
just think if you were found in a hotel
room puking naked prostitute next to you
male prostitute meth on the floor what
would you say probably nothing is what
you would say Gilliam releases a
statement but this has been a wake-up
call for me since my race for governor
ended I fell into a depression that has
led to alcohol abuse I witnessed my
father suffer from alcoholism and I know
the damaging effects it can have when
untreated I also know that alcoholism is
often a symptom of deeper struggles I
will be stepping down from all public
facing roles for the foreseeable future
yeah he apologized and asked for privacy
what a terrible statement what a garbage
shameful statement I would be more than
happy
frankly I'd be more than happy to skip
over the story if the guy's statement
took any responsibility whatsoever for
his actions or owned up to the fact that
he did these things or acknowledged the
naked prostitute next to him or owned up
to the fact that maybe he had something
to do with the meth that was on the
floor he insists I had nothing to do I
never done meth in my life I don't know
what math looks like I don't know what
it is instead he refuses any and all
responsibility look at the
this has been a wake-up call for me oh
good you got a wake-up call that's a
good thing
wow you're so observant you're so
self-aware
I'm wow you're taking responsibility
right because you're it's a wake-up call
so you're waking up since my race for
governor ended I fell into a depression
that's led to alcohol abuse it's not
that he went and hit the bottle it's not
that he betrayed his wife and kids no no
he's a victim he's a victim of losing
the race for governor and he fell he
just felt woops I tripped into alcohol
abuse I witnessed my father suffer from
alcohol abuse
he had a bad childhood I bet that's
another that's another reason he's a
victim total victim no responsibility
he knows the damaging effects alcohol
can have but he fell into it just
happened he fell into the naked male
prostitute on the floor he fell into the
bag of meth on the floor oh whoops
whoopsie Daisy
could happen to anybody I know that
alcoholism is often a symptom of deeper
struggles oh my God he's got deeper
struggles and you have the audacity to
even read about this story how awful I
know people I've got family members and
friends who have struggled with
addiction and alcohol it is a disease
right there is that aspect of it is true
it is something that at a certain point
you really don't have a lot of control
over that you were being pulled by this
compulsion it's very hard to get out of
it right that doesn't mean that you have
no responsibility and I don't I don't
know if Andrew Gilliam is an alcoholic
he might have just picked up a was he an
alcoholic when he called up rentman calm
was he in a drunken stupor when he did
that or did he pre-plan that was he was
that maybe a little more thought-out was
that a little more methodical you can't
just like blame all of your problems on
somebody else you have to take some
responsibility this is what we want our
public servants right the buck stops
here the guy ran for governor of Florida
and and he is caught in a bad as bad a
sex scandal as you can be caught in and
he just tries it was my father's fault
it was the alcohols fault it one
struggling it was my struggles fault
give
a break dude good grief so the other
side of this by the way is the
mainstream media won't talk about it
have you heard of the Android Gilliam
story maybe you saw something passing on
the internet Facebook or Twitter or
something but not a lot this is not
getting wall-to-wall coverage if that
had been a Republican could you imagine
and if a Republican had given that kind
of statement the Republican gave that
kind of statement I would I would be
attacking him just as much as I'm
attacking Andrew Gilliam so repulsive
not to take any responsibility for your
actions but I guess that's the left
being a leftist means never having to
say you're sorry
another left winger who is playing some
really cynical politics is Tom Perez the
chairman of the Democratic National
Committee and I bring it up because it
shows you something I don't think he
meant to show us this but it shows you
two contradictory strategies that the
left has right now on religion religion
is a really tough topic for the left
because the left
ideologically is atheistic I'm not
saying everyone who calls himself a left
winger is necessarily an atheist I'm not
saying every Democrat is necessarily an
atheist but the logical conclusion of
leftism
is atheism that's what we're seeing
today so you see this in particular on
an issue like abortion for years and
years the Democratic Party had a lot of
pro-life people in then starting a few
decades ago with Mario Cuomo the
governor of New York whose son is now
the governor of New York Mario Cuomo
came up with this really really cynical
but brilliant strategy for Catholics and
other faithful people on the question of
abortion when really their religion is
leftism but they want to at least
pretend to be Catholics in public so how
do you do that on the issue of abortion
abortion is kind of the dividing line if
you support abortion you can't be a
Catholic we'll get to that in a second
but if you oppose abortion you can't be
a leftist and this has been building for
a long time so what Mario Cuomo came up
with was he said listen I am personally
against abortion but publicly I'm for
Worsham said what what what it like
you're two different people what does
that mean no personally I oppose
abortion in my secret heart but in
everything that I do and in my role as
governor I'm very pro-abortion say well
then I don't doesn't really matter a lot
to me if you're personally against
abortion because it doesn't have any
effect in the real world but anyway they
got away with this for a long time that
led to then the next stage of the
Democrat relationship to abortion which
was Hillary Clinton who said I think
abortion should be safe legal and rare
say way to saying that doesn't make any
sense
safe abortion is never safe because it
always kills somebody so that's off the
table legal why should it be legal well
I guess the only reason it should be
legal is if it's not morally similar to
killing somebody which we've by the way
already established that it is but if
it's let's let's say that it's not
somehow abortion is not what abortion is
then okay I guess it can be legal
because it's not morally similar to
killing somebody but then why should it
be rare so if it doesn't have moral
gravity to it if it's just like getting
your tonsils out then it should be legal
and it there's no reason for it to be
rare if it should be rare then it
shouldn't be legal because the reason it
should be rare is that it's killing
somebody this it never made any sense
but anyway it got a lot of approval from
the chattering class and allowed left
wingers who struggled with this religion
question to convince themselves that it
was possible to be say Christian and
support abortion which it is not which
we will get to now their past that 2017
Tom Perez said supporting abortion as a
Democrat is non-negotiable
he said Pro lifers are not welcome in
the Democratic Party so cardinal Dolan
who is the Cardinal in New York who
tries to have a nice relationship with
people of both parties he's not a bomb
thrower he's not an arch-conservative to
put it mildly
cardinal Dolan comes out and says quote
it saddens me
that Democrats are considering this
non-negotiable it saddens me and weakens
the democracy millions of Americans
cherish when the party that once
embraced Catholics now slams the door on
us
my Dolan saying you can't even cardinal
Dolan is saying you can't be Catholic
and support abortion so then Tom Perez
comes back with a zinger he just says
quote well actually the majority of
Catholics voted for Democrats in 2016 so
apparently the Cardinal may not
understand that Matthew 25 is a pretty
important teaching and Matthew 25 says
you know when you were hungry I fed you
when you were naked I provided you with
clothing when you were an immigrant I
welcomed you I think one of the reasons
why so many people are moving away from
Donald Trump is that he's abandoned all
those values first of all Catholics
didn't vote for Hillary in 2016 the vote
was split it's 50/50 I'm ashamed to say
that - but she didn't win Catholics
second of all it's like kind of a loose
translation of Matthew 25 that might be
the the authorized Tom Perez version of
Matthew 25 but he leaves out the very
next line and so also in Matthew 25 what
he leaves out is and the king will
answer them truly I say to you as you
did it to one of the least of these my
brethren you did it to me that that
could be the abortion line of all of
Scripture as you did it to the least of
these my brethren the smallest the
quietest ones for that a voice the most
vulnerable you did it to me it's it's
almost comical if it weren't so dark it
would be really funny that the chapter
of Scripture that Tom Perez chooses to
cite as evidence that abortion doesn't
matter and you know you can be
pro-abortion and really Democrats or a
super super Christian or something is
the chapter that includes that verse as
you did it to the least of these my
brethren you did it to me it shows you
two different ways to go two different
ways that the Democrats are trying to
deal with religion Democrats have become
more brazenly leftist and atheist over
the last couple
decades and the two responses to this
are the boo strategy and the booted edge
strategy those are the two responses to
religion the boo strategy is actually
the honest one that one is being honest
about atheism and it comes from when the
Democrats booed God at their National
Convention so Antonio Villaraigosa was
chairing the session at the the
Democratic National Convention they were
going to add in an amendment that
referred to people's god-given potential
and this was controversial because
they've previously taken out the phrase
god-given then that was a big hullabaloo
didn't play very well in Peoria so the
Democrats added back in the language God
given Antonio vo Burgos at the DNC says
all right we're gonna add it in there's
going to be a simple voice vote say say
yay yay say nay nobody was gonna say
name is gonna be easy to put in except
the Democrats at their convention did
not want to add in God is there any
further discussion hearing on the matter
requires a two-thirds vote in the
affirmative all those delegates in favor
say aye
all those delegates opposed say no
and the opinion of the let me do that
again
all of those delegates in favor say aye
all those delegates opposed say no okay
so it's a little awkward isn't it
because he thought this is going to be
very easy and Antonio Vieira goes I
actually know him he and I did a TV show
together here in Los Angeles and he's a
nice guy he's a kind of normal Democrat
as much as a Democrat can be normal at
the party leadership in this day and age
but he's kind of look he wanted I know
he went in there thinking all right this
would be two seconds this would be
really easy we'll get out of there okay
I know okay we're good to go except
that's not what happened noes seemed to
carry him so he doesn't know what to do
so he goes again to the vote I guess
I'll do that one more time all those
delegates in favor say aye all those
delegates opposed say no in the opinion
of the chair 2/3 of voted in the
affirmative the motion is adopted and
the platform has been amended as shown
on the screen thank you very much
and there's the boo you can hear it
because I mean it's obviously hard to
pick up on these microphones regardless
of whether you think the eyes have it or
the noes have it certainly was not the
case that 2/3 of people voted to pass
that amendment and what was the
amendment the amendment was to add God
back into the Democratic party platform
they didn't get their way and they booed
they booed God the boos strategy is
honesty okay the boo strategy is yeah
we're atheists we might have vague
notions of the supernatural because
listen people think that the religious
are the most superstitious people on
earth actually the religious are the
least superstitious people it's the
people who pretend they don't have
religion they're the most superstitious
they got the chakras and the crystals
and the astrology and they go into all
sorts of weird stuff so it's just a
matter of practical religion traditional
religion the boo strategy is we don't
have that anymore
the other strategy is the boo to judge
strategy the Buddha dredge strategy is
where you pretend to be a believer but
you actually openly contradict orthodoxy
and scripture at every single turn you
constantly warp stretched scripture to
mean the opposite of what it plainly
says and what people have said that it
says for all of human history he did
this again on the issue of abortion
peabody judge was on a radio show called
The Breakfast Club and they said you
know man how you gonna square the
abortion issue with how you're always
prattling on about faith and cuz well
actually you know there's a lot in the
scripture that says we should kill a lot
of babies now right now they hold
everybody in line with this one kind of
piece of doctrine about abortion right
which is obviously a tough issue for a
lot of people who think through morally
then again you know there's a lot of
parts of the Bible to talk about how
life begins with breath and so even that
is something that we can interpret
differently and I'm pro-choice pickup me
too but I think no matter where you
think about the kind of cosmic question
of how life begins most Americans can
get on the board with the idea of
alright I might draw the line here you
might draw the line there but the most
important thing is the person who should
be drawing the line is the woman making
the decision absolutely Wow what I'm so
glad that guy went nowhere I'm so glad
he's out of the race Olivia says look
what we might disagree on abortion but
what we should at least agree on is that
we should have abortion we can all agree
on that we should have abortion even if
we disagree on abortion look there's
lots of parts of the Bible let's say
that it's great to kill babies no there
aren't buster maybe Rhea
maybe crack that spine open again give
it another read so anyway that's what
Tom Perez is doing here he's twisting a
chapter of gospel to pretend that it
supports his modernist atheist political
ideology and then he leaves out the
punchline because it contradicts the
very point that he's trying to make
let's make this very simple some
questions are very complicated like
questions of public health and the
global economy and pandemics some
questions are very simple a Christian
cannot support abortion it is not
possible cannot do it a Christian cannot
vote for a political candidate who
supports abortion if there is an
alternative it's a sin to do so the
Catholic Church has always been very
clear about this and most other churches
have to most other denominations most
other groups of believers have felt that
way the Buddha judge Perez strategy is
to just confuse the issue right to say
well it's really complicated it's not
some issues are complicated some issues
are simple actually by the way by the
way before we go the same is true of
socialism I know now that's considered
very complicated at least I speak as a
Catholic the Catholic Church has always
been very clear that socialism must be
completely rejected ok the Catechism of
the Catholic Church says the church has
rejected the totalitarian and atheistic
ideologies associated in modern times
with communism or socialism regulating
the economy solely by centralized
planning perverts the basis of social BA
doesn't mean the church wants no
regulation at all but nobody is
supporting no regulation at all in
mainstream politics there are people
openly supporting socialism some of whom
were still running for president that's
what the left is doing here for over a
century popes have called socialism a
wicked Confederacy a pest a plague that
must be utterly opposed and rejected
Democrats try to confuse this issue they
take one or two verses out of context it
is not unclear it is a simple question
Christians cannot be socialists all
right
the left is going to try to confuse a
lot of things they do this all of the
time this is why it's very important to
look at these issues clearly not to be
pulled away with emotion I think this is
the big theme of of coronavirus forget
about the theme of the 2020 campaign
it's the theme of this pandemic it's the
theme of the times we're living in right
now there are a lot of people who are
trying to emotionally manipulate you
into making bad decisions into panicking
into becoming hysterical into
sentimentality don't do it
this is not the time an important
election or a global pandemic this is
not the time to abandon your faculties
of reason this is when you must be most
vigilant in using those faculties that
you've got oK we've got a lot more to
get to I have to do it tomorrow
hopefully we won't be quarantined
tomorrow because until mayor Garcetti
drags me out of my studio I will be here
with you in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
see them
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
without ski editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka Geneva
production assistant Ryan love the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there